[Música]
y
ruán el puerto europeo más grande para
el transporte de cereales se encuentra a
120 km del mar
para guiar estos buques los más grandes
del mundo se necesitan pilotos
especializados que puedan navegar por el
río sena
hoy este piloto sube a bordo de harbor
un granelero de 175 metros de largo que
transporta 23 mil toneladas de trigo
con dirección a argelia
[Música]
le tengo la puerta
bueno siempre es lo mismo
marcó un clásico
construcción japonesa o china
captar
su capitán tenemos dos remolcadores
eric ue toma el control del buque y le
explica la maniobra salida al capitán
philip y no
a todos en el puerto o harbor pendiente
de la salida 2 kpc de río abajo para el
mar decenas de miles de toneladas de
acero serán movidas por las poderosas
corrientes del río con la ayuda de dos
remolcadores eric orquesta la maniobra
de salida
saliendo ahora los coupés de para el mar
y 940 de calado
partimos a tiempo no hay un tráfico
particular que gestionar pero hay que
estar alerta la cualidad que es yo diría
universal entre nosotros
es la humildad porque nos hemos dado
cuenta con la experiencia de que no
podemos tener ninguna certeza
el carguero sale del puerto de ruán sin
problemas
[Música]
al ritmo de las indicaciones dadas al
timonel
tú tú tú
el barco comienza su lento avance por
las curvas del sena
se necesitan 6 horas de navegación para
llegar al mar desde el puerto de ruán
y a lo largo del viaje los pilotos
tienen que enfrentarse a muchos
obstáculos
aquí eric tendrá que adelantar a este
buque que está cargando en el muelle
lo difícil va a ser ir a un ritmo lento
de puntillas para no hacerlo mover
cuántas miles de toneladas tienen que
pasar de puntillas
unas 40 mil
je je je
je
perfecto no hicimos que se moviera
para estos grandes buques las maniobras
son siempre delicadas porque la más
mínima desviación del canal es fatal
todos los pilotos del sena recuerdan el
portacontenedores que quedó atrapado en
el lecho del río en marzo de 2014
para sacarlo del fango hubo que esperar
a que subiera el nivel del agua en el
sena
sin las mareas el río no tendría la
suficiente profundidad para que los
buques de carga pudieran navegar
el lugar hard work por su parte llegó a
la mitad del camino
es el momento de que los pilotos del
sena tomen el relevo
una operación que se realiza sin detener
el carguero se van 0 2 a 0
se suelen ver atardeceres como este en
el estuario
es uno de los atractivos del sena que
evita cierta rutina cada día hay
paisajes completamente diferentes
one 0
precisamente no le parece que toda esta
naturaleza se ve un poco perturbada e
incluso maltratada por todo este tráfico
es una pregunta seria no somos nosotros
los pilotos los que decidimos tener una
u otra industria en determinado lugar
y nuestro trabajo es ayudar a este
comercio lo mejor que podamos
para que se haga según las reglas con
seguridad y también para la naturaleza y
el medio ambiente
cuando llegan al puente de normandía la
noche ha caído sobre el estuario para el
piloto del viaje pronto llegará a su fin
[Música]
ya casi llegamos al mar así que
tendremos que buscar un refugio para
poder desembarcar con total seguridad
protegida por la masa del carguero la
lancha rápida se ajusta a su velocidad
y desembarcar es una maniobra delicada
tenemos la satisfacción de haber hecho
nuestro trabajo de haber ayudado a
alguien la sonrisa del comandante de
desembarcar o al menos el apretón de
manos
es algo cálido y lo apreciamos
luego una vez y fomento
los pilotos del sena por su parte mañana
se pondrán al mando de uno de los 3000
buques de carga que atraviesan cada año
el parque natural de los meandros del
sena
[Música]
[Aplausos]